It's been a wild few weeks
in the worlds of news
and by popular demand
you've blown up the phones
begging us to bring back flannel
again that's one thing we have
we're pitting the professionals
against each other as we always
do to see who has kept
the closest track of the weird
things that have happened
the past week the winner awarded
prizes from the Tucker Carlson
store this week's first
contestant is Trump Campaign
Legal advisor Jenna Ellis is
on the show quite a bit tonight
she's making her final exam
debut she's facing off against
Guy Benson host of the Guy
Benson Show on Fox News radio
thanks to you both for coming
on I hope
you're a little bit nervous oh
wait we are totally but you know
that it's a privilege just to be
nominated tiger love it good
please thank the little people
made it possible all right you
know the rules I know
you've been studying but in case
you missed them.
Here they are hands on buzzers I
ask the questions.
The first one to buzz in gets
to answer you have to wait this
is critical until I finish
asking until you answer could
answer one technology by saying
your name every correct answer
is worth one point you get it
wrong we take a point away first
to file wins ready right all
right this is question 1 now we
were asked by the National game
show commission in Billings,
Montana to begin with a question
about food and so of course we
are it's a multiple choice OK
it's about Dunkin' Donuts it was
just revealed that a new donut
is entering the market with
a brand new glaze on it is that
glaze a hot sauce be barbecue
sauce or C spicy mustard Guy
Benson I'm going to go with
barbecue barbecue
that's a sensible answer is it
right here we go and by this say
what food Dunkin' Donuts
revealing the hottest donut
of the year they're serving
bright red hot sauce to release
a hot sauce jelly donut oh m.j.
being sensible he's that come
Tucker no actually that's a very
deep point not in 2020 does not
do better question 2 is again
a multiple choice or wait
for all the options please which
presidential candidate famous
for talking about climate change
in the most concern way was
spotted looking appropriately
sheepish getting off a private
jet recently was it a Bernie
Sanders b Elizabeth Warren seat
Tom Steyer I mean ask the judges
tell me who got to the first two
that John Ellis yes it was
Elizabeth Warren and she should
have let sheepish she was hiding
with Warren and she should have
looked sheepish is Janet correct
she looks very she does look
proud she's not
taking a selfie to put
on Instagram for the G4 why is
that kind of weird all right
question 3 nice shot this is
a very tough one.
So it's going to be another
multiple choice here Sunday was
Groundhog Day,
February 2nd and we're reminded
of the 2014 tragedy in which New
York City mayor and known
incompetent Mayor Bill de Blasio
dropped Staten Island Chuck
sadly the Groundhog died after
hitting the ground we learned
the Groundhog wasn't actually
called Chuck I would call him
Chuck for Chuck what was his
real name was it a Charlotte was
it B Brooklyn was it c Gabby I
got nothing I don't OK you see
it was big but you just got me
to lose a point yes I do yes
yeah I'm not falling for that
guy what happens if we
don't want to wait it out wait
a minute I'm going to count
to 3.
How about this one we'll sweeten
the pot Sarah judges obvious
you're going to be guessing
we'll make it a two point
question you get two points
if you get it right and we
won't subtract a point if you
get it wrong oh OK then
I'll buzz in for that and try OK
I will say it's b Brooklyn b
Brooklyn OK rotate please is it
Brooklyn another borough this
footage from Groundhog Day 2014
shows freshly inaugurated Mayor
Bill de Blasio appearing to drop
Staten Island Chuck about a week
later,
the animal died and only now are
the circumstances of his death
starting to emerge and also
coming to light is this Staten
Island Chuck was actually Staten
Island Charlotte a female stand
in unfortunately that was not
correct but we are not
subtracting a point
because you're brave enough
to guess we ought to encourage
wild guessing on the show OK
so here we are to question
for and this is not a multiple
choice which 20 2020 candidate
says he has a strict policy
of never calling people
on their birthdays either who
wins who made the 911 call
people on their birth it sounds
like the president honestly no
it's it's a candidate yes please
well it's
up to the candidate but I never
decide like me like
so so you're encouraging wild
guessing right so I never I
never called people
on their birthday it's not hard
I never call people
on their birthdays
it's a straightforward question
he's over 70.
I just don't know the answer
they're all over 70 fine all
right well what if the guests I
will go with Joe Biden was it
Joe Biden what are you likely
to fail at to do poorly
as president look I
don't tolerate terribly well
I'm not good at Pleasantries you
have your birthday I'm not going
to call you up to congratulate
you so you'll love me
and you're right nice things
about me let's love what I do I
should get on with the grumpier
yeah I mean,
Biden is that kind of guy who
would do you know what
he'd probably forget it was
your birthday but if he
remembered he would call you all
right back rub this is easy
because we're 0 0 going in now
it's a multiple choice you may
be one of the millions of people
who watch the Super Bowl ratings
were up for the first time
in five years.
How many people tuned
in to the Super Bowl this year
these are tough questions
but you have three options OK
and don't hesitate if you've got
a sense go for it was it a $88
million was a B 102 million was
it c 155 million people die b it
was B was it B to the tape
Sunday's Super Bowl brought
in huge numbers for Fox we were
the network that ran it how many
watched 102 million viewers
watched the Chiefs win over
the 49ers one of the 10th most
watched ever no and you are
right did you know that it was
not a guess too no I knew
and I'm just glad I didn't blow
the Fox trivia question that
might not play well up in New
York with our bosses
so I'm relieved that I got it
right right it was it was
in your morning information
packet yes thank you
congratulations to you Jenna
good job you're an excellent
dancer an enthusiastic one
and that counts on this show
though right thank you
congratulations to you both yes.